if donald trump does run and is the  republican nominee in 2024  he has a really good shot at winning  based on what's going on today things  can change but based on what's going on  today  i don't know that i see joe biden  defeating trump in a rematch this is not  you know people will write to me they'll  say david you're you're poisoning the  well now i just tell you things the way  i see them right now i don't know that i  see biden defeating trump in a rematch  if biden doesn't run in its kamala as  i've outlined before i don't know that i  see kamala defeating donald trump this  is just me being real and of course us  knowing this and getting together around  it could prevent it from happening  but  my preference is to soundly defeat  trumpists in the midterms  so that trump hopefully sees  this is not looking good for me all of  my strongest followers or many have been  defeated and chooses not to run to avoid  the embarrassment of another loss